resident evil 7 is just over a month  away and Capcom has high hopes for  launch day in fact the company would  like to see 4 million copies sold on day  one in an interview with MCV marketing  director Antoine Malone said it's  capcom's biggest release on new consoles  as for the four million sales he stated  that would be great looking at what we  see in the pre-orders and trends these  days were pretty confident we are going  to get there all the signs that we have  seen across the market whether it's from  the UK or from other territories are  very positive so far the confidence is  there we'll see if they hit that total  when resident evil 7 comes to ps4 xbox  one and pc on january 24th other games  in the series have sold in the millions  so it's certainly possible to keep up  with all the latest from Resident Evil  and Capcom you're already in the right  place  you